this episode brought to you by
expressvpn the best VPN there is take
back your online privacy today
[Music]
so tree who has your horse well thanks
for the swamps of sadness I found out he
has crippling depression oh wow yeah but
thankfully an apple filled with Prozac
and literally drowning in his own
despair let him run up well that's got
to be better than you return not as am i
right
well after being chased by a woman with
the decapitated head through a hallway
with screaming faces I think I'd prefer
the shock therapy
man this is so crazy I had no idea there
were so many survivors of 80s kids films
thanks for inviting me to this Falcon
well you know I had an invite one of
those Cooper's from Dark Crystal
three teen survivals of the bride to
colorful time known as the a tune to
hand out our awards winner of smallest
survival in a scary as shit eighties
kids film is a tie between mrs. Brisby
and fifo
for tear off so much I know Python would
also love to accept this award but he
seems to have mysteriously disappeared
for the night I dedicate this award to
Don Bluths disturbing phobia of cats I
mean seriously who names the feline
dragon thank you I just hope this brings
awareness to the dangers of clown
fireman's and also a Peter Lorre sound
in the layoffs how racially insensitive
for the only black person in any of
these dark kid's fantasy movies his
passing his grandson Malcolm ray thank
you all for being a bunch of racist
crackers the name of the kid was from
the witches
[Applause]
this year thank you it's a no secret
that this film inflicted great
psychological damage on my psyche but
knowing that the damage done was
inflicted tenfold on millions of
children across the nation just warms my
heart
wait a minute I just have to win that
award it's tarin ooh I'm the Black
Cauldron he's an honorary mention thinks
he's on the same level as other 80s dark
movies but he's I guess Black Cauldron
isn't the most liked movie huh did you
dare say you did it like black coal 3
well ya know anything like no what do
you likes Black Cauldron but that
doesn't mean you don't like Black
Cauldron
[Music]
developed in the 70s black culture went
through a lot of reworking until its
premiere in 1985 apparently was passed
from creative team to creative team
constantly ate up money being the most
expensive animated film at the time and
was heavily edited down because Jeffrey
Katzenberg freaked when he saw kids
running out of pre screenings due to how
scary it was wow this sounds kind of
badass when it came out it was not very
well received by critics or audiences in
fact it lost to the Care Bears movie
that had already been out for several
months I think that's the worst thing
I've ever heard it was often referred to
as the film that almost destroyed Disney
over the years though it's grown a cult
following being praised by fans of dark
80s movies and cheering it for being the
black sheep of Disney cinema yeah people
were great understanding it was too dark
for their brainwashed Disney Minds did
you challenge me you coward Oh
four days finest warrior draws his last
breath this would take minutes to wash
out yeah a few things give you things I
don't get it is Black Cauldron like this
lost dark masterpiece or is it just an
awkward forgettable mess it's
complicated I'll tell you what why don't
you watch it on my phone and decide for
yourself while we tend to proto bastard
here good luck well let's see if it's
worth the praise is gonna or the hate
it's gotten this is Black Cauldron if
I'm open solid enough with the
description of what the Black Cauldron
is there was once a king so cruel and so
easy that even the gods feared and
everyone was freaked out by those BK ads
then a Black Cauldron was made to
conceal the Kings evil and whoever
possessed it could raise an army of the
Dead
so obviously this evil King is the bad
guy right nope never mentioned again
kind of odd they were building him up so
much if in Lord of the Rings would it
add up if they were like the spirit of
Sauron
indeed Sauron has returned well let's
see what the White Witch is up to
she's fine we've been cut to a cottage
where a wizard may be man named Alban
looks after a boy named Taryn with an
American accent as a Terran or Turan now
I'm just gonna call him tearing because
his voice is tearing through my earlobes
like a monolith of annoyance is this to
be my life
pampering a pig I'm a warrior
Terran I'm 100% convinced is the lost
Disney Princess now I know that doesn't
sound right seeing how there's
technically a Disney princess in this
later but she doesn't have as many
Disney Princess traits as he does for
example he's very delicate and Fae but
I'm afraid he lives in a cottage is
unhappy with his life has no mother and
yearns for more Dubin doesn't understand
I'm not a little boy anymore I should be
doing heroic deeds for breeding even his
design is very Disney Princess esque
look at him if you just switch the hair
it's pretty damn close your head your
time man you're breaking down barriers'
you don't even know you break it down
there is the minor issue though that the
yearning part I was talking about is
actually more whining if you replaced
actually more with your fisting Lee
obsessive I'm a warrior hanwen hanwen
it's always hearing I'm a warrior ever
be anything but an assistant pinky I'm a
would be a famous warrior laureate what
I need is a it's a charm of warrior
better eat it I'm a water give me
you challenged me you got dirty he
doesn't like you I know the idea is to
show he's cocky and not ready for the
world he's about to enter but there's a
difference between Peter Parker cocky
and Howard the Duck cocky one has charm
and how naive he is and the other is
Howard the Duck don't be like Howard the
Duck Todd he looks after a pig named hen
one who they only keep around because a
spider said she was cool it was weird
when she suddenly ceased something so
terrible she can't contain it so the pig
has magical powers when you put her face
in water she can predict the future cool
when my hamster puts his balls and
kool-aid he can watch Gilligan's Island
what the hell kind of power is that I
mean come on a map and the moonlight
reveals hidden letters playing a flute
over fire can summon magic imagery
shoving a pig's face and a toilet can
get you lottery numbers it just doesn't
seem particularly whimsical Fantasia
she's showing us better Disney films
best leave out some of the racier sent
our scenes but no the Horned King has
discovered it we're not really sure how
he discovered it oh we must have been
their drunken Instagram post yeah that
makes sense
I'm not afraid of the Horned King then
you were already foolish lad really
there was the tipping point for you
taken went to the hidden cottage at the
edge of the Forbidden Forest
good boy Toby I won't fail you he's
totally gonna fail me so much what
sobbing why don't you come with me oh
well the cats and the boots and I still
send out from physical Netflix DVDs yes
I'm the one we then cut to the castle of
the Horned King beautifully accompanied
by Elmer Bernstein's recycled goes our
theme
[Music]
the working is voiced by legendary actor
John Hurt who offers a pretty chilling
read with the exception of when he's
rushed here and there like he was doing
so good in any fan out he didn't put
money in his parking meter soon the
Black Cauldron will be my yes Arne is so
aware of his important mission to keep
and win safe they stops right in the
middle of it to fantasize about himself
being a hero thus losing her thank you
thank you thank you all
oh no my fantasies of sexy Big Bird are
getting in the way of my fantasies of
heroism her real nights don't have to
stay focused do they but without the
help of my Pig hen one here
I'm Henry oh no that was really the best
take your head oh no I'm going to have
my favorite cereal oh no this isn't my
favorite cereal oh well uh still port in
a bowl
oh no we're out of bowls
oh well I'll still get the toy that's
inside oh just when you think our leads
can get any more annoying
Oh deep Bible mentions approaches this
is gurgi groupies if the shaggy dogs
asked farted jar jar binks his voice no
matter how often you asked him to stop
smacking and wacky hate and yes dear
viewer he's in a lot of the movie
margins a bitch never sharp eye cookies
for a big even now go give me numbers
yes a sweet first come to find us
like please what happened oh yeah
oh I get it someone was like I bet you
can't trick Disney animators into
drawing Wilford Brimley's armpit hair on
the Pokemon doll of Mark Twain with the
death rattle of Donald Duck and some say
this bastard was like watch me very
annoying meal and ride and wind is found
too late though as she's grabbed by the
satanic cold a figment and taken to the
Horned King and on such a lovely
rotoscope day to if great not going to
even cancer poor girl you will never see
his friend again you know if you say one
more thing like call his wife queefing
we're never gonna see gurgi again either
Taryn goes to the horn king's castle
with such good security he can climb
right up the walls in such good
architecture they goes through a door
that leads to beams on the ceiling my
design did the Winchester Susie that's a
confuse the spirit all because she was
drunk whoa Esmerelda's been taking some
liberties with her branding shit now
just think of a funnier version of
hellfire I feel I see the Sun coltan
horizon hair don't shave me it's my
thing I just love
[Music]
yeah we always have to look amazed every
time he comes in even those is like the
millionth room he's entered oh he's
going to the kitchen he comes in to do
the laundry
Cantor's the bathroom it would be so bad
if this explosive demon flatulence
didn't follow him and every entrance
seriously it smells like an tits ass in
here can we all not just eat we'd come
across shaved Turkey who's the horn
king's assistant named creeper who
brings in the captured hanwen they can't
get it to show where the Black Cauldron
is but thankfully it's raining flops I
presume my boy you are the keeper of
this Iraq cannot be you know there's
some words that just can't be make free
be even with John Hurt's amazing voice
I'm convinced pig is one of them I mean
come on you're the owner of this animal
the owner of this creature the owner of
this peak I just keep expecting to see
him in babe like that'll do Pig that
don't do now die actually I'm not too
far off as they threatened to chop her
head off if he doesn't show them how to
get the visions and man was this an
awkward image when I paused it while
reviewing Oh Mike I tell you not just
bet you pleased to say the magic words
that shows them the black cauldrons
location your leash that noise beyond my
reach okay that pigs tripping balls face
is one of the funniest things I've ever
seen what if it's not all folks what if
it's just the beginning folks but Taran
trips spilling the water onto the horn
Kings face I'm melting I met wait why
does this happen
none of course when pigs tell the future
in water it instantly becomes toxic who
wrote this
you know I got a same as pinkies origin
stories a lot more aggressive than I
thought it'd be so they locked her in a
way and he's all alone to think about
his thoughts though my escape failed
I'll try again tomorrow
but a girl sneaks into his cell and
admits she's being held prisoner - I'm
princess Eilonwy princess what I'm
princess Eilonwy
is something only barb in this look
there's hair in Kapaa fur there's gonna
be kill I'll submit the fur
behold obnoxio d of shut up your names
all sound like preservatives so princess
although Holly looks over the situation
are you a lord or a warrior I'm an
assistant Pig Keeper oh what a pity
bitch she's more of a princess than
you'll ever be actually there's some
truth to that there is absolutely no
reason for her to be a princess she
never uses her Authority we never see
her Kingdom there's no royal family
members that enter the picture it's
completely pointless I think she was
just embarrassed to say what she really
did for a living I'm an assistant Pig
Keeper
well I'm assistant shit cleanup princess
yes that's it princess really of what
kingdom shut your hos vo sounds
Norwegian thank God the guards are on
vacation as they sneak easily through
the place and find the tomb of the king
who used to own the castle he must have
been a great warrior the shield is the
second marker
he graduates from pit keeping the
grave-robbing as he steals the Kings
sword and then they notice the henchmen
bringing in a ton of dead bodies stop we
should help him
they also come across a minstrel who's
being locked up for stealing designs
from the Aristocats you seem an
intelligence old chap to me I had no
idea who boy even by Disney dumb faces
that was a really dumb face
maybe he just saw John Malkovich in bird
box and couldn't believe he couldn't
stop making the sucking on hummingbirds
penis face his name is what who not what
who not pickles I'm calling him pickles
so Taran pickles and Princess lonely
band together to try and escape but oh
no they come across a guard with an axe
look out he might use his hand but
luckily is so it is a singing sword
[Music]
look here it says only the lamest shall
weird me well as long as I don't have to
do in the actual hero work okay
seriously did he just skip
they're very merrily getting away to get
to the castle entrance but fine they're
locked in so the princess hugs the door
I can demand that you save us only for
so long you know the thought occurs to
me we're really terrible to what we do
our heroes escape as creeper goes to
tell the Horned King the bad news you
bring news of the pig I'm sorry it's
still funny there's just some words that
take you out of a threatening tone you
bring news of the cookies you bring news
of Walla Walla Washington you bring news
of the dummy muffin cuckoo butter it
can't be done he sends out his dragons
to find them while our heroes take a
minute to recoup they're almost finished
leader it's not too good oh just like my
bowels I wasn't afraid like we were
running for our lives well I got us out
of the castle didn't I yeah I'd say it
was the swords magic no need to point
out how useless he is film he doesn't
quite naturally on his own ha what does
a girl know about sorts anyway at least
I don't keep talking about it
silly girl I hugged a door which is more
than the wood that you offering thank
you for getting me out of the dungeon so
just as fast as they blow up at each
other they patch things up as we also
see the return of
turn off lock the door or make a door so
we can lock it you know we make sure
this is an underrated classic it's
complicated
[Applause]
[Music]
it's so easy to steal someone's identity
nowadays watch hi chaplain your kita now
do you like being Keaton
[Laughter]
on line this is done all the time that's
why you need expressvpn without a VPN in
general your internet browsing data can
be tracked by your ISP as well as your
cellular provider and companies and
hackers when you use a VPN like
expressvpn your public IP address is
masked so even the websites you visit
won't be able to identify it it also
encrypts your internet data preventing
others from sniffing your information
over the network on top of that you can
also unblock content accessing content
that's only available in some countries
but expressvpn is the best because it
has the fastest speeds server locations
in 94 countries 24/7 customer support
whenever you need it that's for every
device Windows iOS Android Mac Linux
router and so many more and on top of
that it's easy to use you connect with
just one click
it's internet without restriction
securely stream or download content from
anywhere anytime
no activity or connection logs your data
is your business I guess that's why it's
the market leading VPN and read it the
number one VPN service by TechRadar and
on top of protecting all your
information it's cheap as hell less than
seven dollars a month with a 30-day
money-back guarantee I use it because my
data and identity matters a lot to me as
well as the identity of my cat how's it
going
take back your internet privacy today
and find out how you can get three
months free by clicking the link in the
description box expressvpn comm slash
nostalgia critic that exp r e-- s s VPN
comm slash nostalgia critic for three
months free with a one-year package
visit expressvpn calm slash a nostalgia
critic to find out more
take back your privacy today don't be
like keaton or is it chaplin with two
N's now how do you like that chaplin
with two ends
this is expressvpn dot-com / nostalgia
critic to learn more
[Music]
[Applause]
so where heroes fall down a whirlpool
and come across the Smurfs snorkel old
buds that raise the question you know
everyone's asking directors kids cameo
our producers kids cameo well at least
the performances are matched by their
awkward as hell freeze frames seriously
you could start a photo playlist with
these the chubby bearded guy in every
fantasy you'll fit right in farm boy and
every fantasy princess in every fantasy
and comic relief in every fantasy Disney
we welcome new dreams and ideas as long
as they've been done before we were
about to sentence her to death for
eating 12 of our people it's only
fitting you watch tell me is the burning
and killing still going on up there
well Katzenberg is still in charge if
that's what you mean they tell them
where they can find the Black Cauldron
and they plan to destroy it to stop the
Horned King they come across mad madam
mins brothel and break in to see if they
can find it we can clearly say to you
you know he's growing on me like a cyst
they come across Winnie the Pooh's pot
collection for the prototype for hocus
pocus appear and threatened to turn them
into frogs let's play how many fetishes
were created with this scene enough
we've come for the Black Cauldron
perhaps I might interest you in
something else what could you possibly
what were you want the sword once again
does all the work and the witches agreed
to trade the Black Cauldron for it no
time no it's our only chance is it your
own choice chuckling you could be the
greatest of all
I offer my dearest possession you've had
that thing for a day I mean if I had a
chance to trade the end of the world for
a gun that never missed it wouldn't be a
big deal I mean I use on him first and
then the bargain is made and the giant
cauldron is revealed destroying the
house yeah with this thing now for some
reason when the Black Cauldron rises we
turn to Franken berries fart fantasies I
don't know they tell them that the
cauldrons evil can only be stopped if
someone willingly sacrifices himself by
jumping in cool put a piece of sugar in
there and wait for a bug to fly in yeah
I saw then two seconds these dumbasses
still spend the whole night trying to
figure something out I let you down
without my soda I'm nothing I believe
you want to toss yourself in that
cauldron I'll totally dedicate something
to you for the villains find them and
take them back to the castle where the
Horned King uses the cauldron to bring a
bunch of skeletons back to life he finds
them and sets them free I must stop the
cauldron I'm sorry I lonely my mind is
made up this movie's a lost cause and I
want out but get this
gurgi decides to sacrifice himself oh no
now gurgi No
[Music]
Savas Claude yes JB we all shed a tear
when you gave your life for us
hey everybody it me everybody fit me
everybody don't is this not a champion
[Music]
so the Horde king's army starts to fall
it can't be
have you checked our internet connection
it can be wonky some dice Terran almost
gets sucked in as the Horned King spots
him and no joke the entire climax of
this movie is just him holding on to the
wall why isn't the heroic action in this
movie just clinging to architecture oh
and shoving clinging on to shit and
shoving the physical demands of fighting
for bedsheets on a twin size mattress
[Music]
so the bare minimum our heroes save the
day but that still doesn't bring back
gurgi try I guess this good was wanted
and he's still not satisfied
but witches come to take the cauldron
back which makes you wonder what they
want with it or the sword for that
matter you know who are these people
anyway pickles decides to finally do
something in this movie and bargain for
it yes the cauldron for gurgi I was
hoping we could kill him again perhaps
we'll call it this time so which is
agree and oh boy Gary's back well you
may be back agita once I report that on
social media your gray ass is grass
thus we end on the film's final gripping
whine well that was memorable in that
you made Kaylee from quest for Camelot
look like friggin Joan of Arc
and that was the Black Cauldron is it
worth the praise or criticism that's
gotten over the years it's complicated
the characters and story range from
forget ibly bland to frustratingly
annoying but at the same time it is an
impressive film given the time it was
released and the company who released it
this is the closest Disney will ever get
to a watership down or a Wizards that
strange combo of both cheap-looking and
epic looking while hovering over a dart
style most parents would be afraid to
show their kids though what that's it
it's really that dark there's darker
themes and ideas and other Disney
properties these creatures we've seen in
other Disney movies and even some of the
wilder more imaginative stuff some of
them designed by a young Tim Burton
weren't used because they were seen as
too weird so it doesn't even really have
enough of an odd factor to make it that
unique but it was edited down 12 minutes
were cut from this film and you know
that would have saved the movie would it
though anything's possible apparently
there was a lot more gore and violence
in the original cut that most likely
would have resulted in an r-rated that
does make the reputation for a more
attractive as we can just blame the
clothes mida pansies weren't ready to
venture too far from their fairy tales
but here's the thing you'd still have
these guys as your main characters could
the longer edit have added to their
development I suppose so but it's kind
of like saying there's an edit of
Phantom Menace that may Jar Jar Binks
work or an edit of son of the mass that
makes Jamie Kennedy work sure it's
possible but it's very unlikely
especially given their performance and
characteristics but even taking all that
into account
I get why a lot of people like this
movie it is the most consistently dark
looking of the Disney films almost every
environment is grey and swampy it is an
old-school retro feel than most people
associate with dark Andy's kids films
and while it still keeps some Disney
tropes alive it did attempt to take a
few risks it is kind of cool that's
something this consistently grey and
threatening is in Disney's hand-drawn
library those elements I think makes
some people more forgiving of the
standard characters and story go for
them if it does there's a lot to
appreciate from the animation the
backgrounds the risks taken and even the
flawed production history it's all
interesting to look at whatever your
thoughts it's an interesting film to
check out particularly if you're a big
fan of those darkanian's kids movies not
because it always works but because it's
fascinating to see how and why it works
in some areas and not in others and then
compared to how similar films either
succeeded or failed as well it's a hot
mess but it's an interesting complex and
interesting always warrants
[Music]
who you I'm Sara the whiny pain in the
ass from labyrinth I'm Terry don't want
a pain in the ass from the Black
Cauldron do you constantly tell people
about how awesome you are without ever
actually doing anything I do
do you blame everyone else for your
problems and expect to be like I do
let's see their love or Facebook
come let us embark on a trip I use
health fantasy where the lessons learned
are shaky at best
is there any other kind
[Music]
I'm the Nostalgia Critic and I guess
there's always an obnoxious tool for
another obnoxious tool levanto except
Gerty oh I'm a warrior
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week is the ground meme
foundation because poverty and hunger
often go hand in hand they innovate to
solve the problems the poorest people in
the world face they use digital
technology and partner networks to
create solutions that bring financial
agricultural and health services to
several households as part of these
solutions they help to build empowering
ecosystems that support breakthroughs in
health income equity confidence and
capacity every breakthrough counts and
you can play a big part in many of them
with an A rating on charity watch it's
definitely worth clicking on the link
and seeing what you can give or share to
help out
you
[Music]